so I can tell you it's not much of a
surprise in fact I don't know if my
voice will even last until the end of
this talk unfortunately for some reason
my talks of the past few PI data events
while they were put on the schedule
there's always been some problem or a
title has been given to me the last talk
that I gave was at PI data London it was
called Python and Johnny Cash
I think this talk should be called
Python and Tom Waits
because my voice is really scratchy No
okay next year I'll teach I'll teach you
Tom Waits is anyway another thing that
I'm trying to do this year is I'm trying
to give as many new talks as possible so
this is an interesting idea that I had
for a project that I wanted to work on
that could solve a common problem that I
have when using a lot of data science
libraries before I get started as with
all my talks I just like to say we're at
PI data Berlin this is the third event
it's Saturday May 21st 2016 so let me
describe the problem to you but before I
get into that I just want to tell you a
kind of problem this is this is an
engineering problem and I really like
this problem because unlike computer
science problems or mathematics problems
engineering problems often have no one
true answer it's down to a lot of
judgment and it's down to what you think
you can do to get some useful work done
there is no 100% correct answer or
complete answer there's actually no way
to solve this problem completely but
there's a lot of work that we can do in
order to make things better there is no
algorithm available trust me the core
problem here which is that Python is
impossibly is that impossible to static
statically analyze is not something that
we'll be able to solve but there are
some heuristics and I want to show you
one interesting heuristic also another
problem is this is a new talk so I only
have a couple of results I don't have a
finished product and so I'd love if any
of you are interested in trying to solve
this problem that you might come up and
we could talk and see if there's some
work that could be done to move this
forward so one thing is I haven't solved
this problem there's only a couple of
snippets of code that'll be provided
when these slides go online so let me
describe the problem for you I'm in my
ipython notebook or my Jupiter notebook
and I'm writing a little bit of code so
I just use numpy and I create a linear
space and I
just create a parabola I have X and X
squared and I decide to plot it and I
know a matplotlib I have my PI plot sub
library and I have this plot function
and I plot it but I want to change this
plot a little bit
I want the plot to be in green instead
of blue and I kind of know that I can
pass this third parameter G as a string
and that works and maybe instead of a
line I wanted to have plus as the
markers but as I get more and more into
this and I want to do more with my graph
I need to figure out well what does this
plot function actually support so I look
at the help text for the plot function
and this is why I call it the quark
problem whenever you see the help text
and it says quarks you go quark because
you can't really figure out what this
function takes now the matplotlib
developers here have been kind of good
and they've worked against their own
interests because they have hard-coded
into the doc string what some of the
quarks are and where the quarks come
from and they've added a dependency that
they have to maintain for our benefit
but you can see the choirs could be all
of these things and yet they don't tell
us what the arguments are in the
signature itself this turns out to be a
very common problem because maybe I'm
doing something in pandas I create a
data frame and I call top plot in that
data frame and it doesn't quite do what
I expect so I look at the help text and
I see more arts and quarks and in the
case of pandas you see the quartz right
here it doesn't really tell me what
those quarks would be or where they come
from I know they're being passed on to
libraries down the chain because both
this matplotlib pie plot plot is a
convenience function and pandas is full
of these convenience functions and
they're being passed to poor libraries
that matplotlib or parts of matplotlib
in the case of matplotlib or core
libraries in the case of pandas that are
actually consuming these arguments so
let's try and analyze very very
simplistically where this problem is and
how deep this problem goes so I'll just
use the inspect module to write a very
simple function that will just tell me
given a function I'll grab it signature
and I'll see does that signature take
star star keyword arcs and then I'll
write a really simple little lambda then
I'll just go through a module and find
all the columns in that module
and I'll just take the average of those
so I'll see what's the average number of
collar balls exposed by this module that
has the star star keyword arcs and I'll
run it over a couple of simple packages
packages that I have installed in my you
know unmodified anaconda three so you
can see for pandas over 40% of the
things that are available that the
collar bowls by this very rough metric
the collar bowls that are available to
you when you import pandas SPD you do PD
dot whatever almost over 40% of them
have keyword arguments in the case of
matplotlib it's actually not that bad
only 10% in the case of simp i
surprisingly a lot of simp I which I
don't use that much takes keyword
arguments and you can see in the case of
some other libraries like numpy and SK
learn and bouquet there's almost no
usage of keyword arguments so you might
expect that if you're looking at the
help text for something like SK learn or
bouquet and help text might be a lot
more helpful you might have better
autocomplete you might be able to
understand where arguments are passed in
because it doesn't have this ambigú
ating keyword argument problem whereas
my situation when i use pen as a mat
plot lib is all the time i'm trying to
figure out what arguments is this
function take because i want to slightly
modify what this function does in the
case of a plot I want to slightly modify
how that plot looks and I can't figure
out what is what's the magic combination
of parameters I need to pass so that one
parameter passed into that plot gets
passed to the marker object to create
custom markers that look a special way
so let's try and understand why this
problem exists because an easy thing
that we could tell the library authors
is to stop using keyword arguments it's
a great part of the language but don't
use it and of course that's a bad thing
to say I mean keyword arguments are a
great part of language and you'll see
why that is if we look at the libraries
that have this keyword argument problem
there are mostly libraries that provide
us a lot of conveniences what happens is
when you're writing a core library that
fulfills some fundamental tasks you
probably know what arguments a function
takes but when you're adding convenience
on top you want to wrap those core
libraries there's core
pieces of functionality but you don't
want to create a dependency between the
convenience layer and the actual code
that it's wrapping if you were to create
that dependency then every single time
something at matplotlib changes the
pandas authors would have to change the
arguments that their functions take but
they don't care about what arguments are
being passed down the line to matplotlib
so instead what they want to do is they
just want a very lightly wrap the
underlying functionality give you a
slightly nicer interface to it but not
block you from doing anything with the
core library that you could do if you
are using it directly so in the case of
pandas is a fantastic case of this
because think think about how much you
use numpy or matplotlib without actually
ever explicitly importing numpy or
matplotlib in your code you do it all
through some convenience layer provided
by pandas and the pandas authors do not
want to manage the documentation burden
or the code burden of having to change
the arguments that are passed to these
convenience methods every single time
the underlying libraries change so it's
necessary that we allow authors to use
these keyword arguments the question is
how can we improve the documentation so
that we don't have the case with
matplotlib where you have to have
somebody statically managing a doc
string and where the arguments are going
and where you can provide a little bit
more information to the user now there
are a couple of guidelines for how we go
about solving this problem our task here
is to pierce this quark veil we have a
function and we don't know what gets
passed into it we don't know what
keyword arguments gets passed into it
and we want to do our best to pierce
that veil we want to figure out at least
a couple of them we may we may miss some
of the keyword arguments as long as we
don't get it completely wrong we're
actually doing a little bit better you
might think that if you're autocomplete
gives you a couple more suggestions than
it did otherwise that might be an
improvement and so you can see why I
call this an engineering problem one
interesting thing about this problem is
because the goal is to supplement the
documentation it frees us to use some
very obscure techniques because a lot of
techniques that we wouldn't use in
building libraries themselves we could
use in order to supplement the
documentation because the actual
deliverable here
is a fairly static product that doesn't
change that much it changes per release
of the code and so you could add this as
some additional pass whenever you do
check-ins or as part of your continuous
integration process a great thing about
this is we don't have to be a hundred
percent complete or correct in fact the
information that we're providing to
users now is very incomplete so anything
better than what we're providing now is
I think an improvement we can be
incomplete we can fail to say that an
argument takes the specific quark as
long as you put a little star star at
the end and say by the way here the
quarks that we can figure out are
actually being passed in and here and it
may take some other ones that we
couldn't determine and that might be
enough and in some cases like in the
plot example that might be enough to
give people just a little bit more
information to solve a couple more
common problems you could think that if
you did that and then supplemented that
with some human effort you might get
very close to having complete
documentation and the ability to do
correct complete Auto completion in your
IDE or you chip it or notebook now of
course at the same time we want to be
careful that we don't list a quark as
being an argument for a function that is
an action argument so we can't be
completely wrong but we can be somewhat
incomplete another thing is we might be
able to focus on the simplest cases here
one thing that we'll see when we look at
a static approach to solving this
problem is that by its very nature
Python is impossible to statically
analyze and as a consequence a malicious
library author like me could construct
situations in which there's no way that
you could determine what arguments could
be passed into a function without
actually calling that function itself
and waiting for it to throw a value
error or some other exception however
we're typically doing this in order to
supplement our usage of common libraries
that were written by common people that
were written to be usable and so we can
focus on much simpler cases than what we
might expect from a pathological library
author so I want to give you two
possible solutions to this and I want to
show you why one solution completely
fails to work even though it's probably
the solution most people would think of
and I want to show you a somewhat
secure solution that I think might work
if we could apply enough effort to it so
the first solution is static analysis if
this was something like C or C++
immediately you'd say well we just
statically analyze the codebase and in a
language like C that might kind of work
but actually in C that doesn't even
really work one static analysis tool or
one static analysis question that I
asked C programmers and C++ programmers
is when you're in a file in a C or C++
program and you see that it's calling
function f how do you find what source
file that function f was defined in and
the only answer I've ever gotten was C
scope or your IDE because it's very
difficult for you to determine what was
included I mean you can track the
includes you can use your GCC and expand
the includes but you end up with a
humongous mess and it can be very
difficult to figure out where that ended
up and that include is only going to
tell you the signature of that function
it won't tell you the linkage and so you
may not actually know what the linkage
is without looking at the build system
so even and C it's very difficult to
determine statically how a function is
called or where a function comes from
and that's ignoring the situation with
things like virtual functions and the
dynamic features that you have available
in C++
however in Python we might think that
simple Python code might be amenable to
static analysis I will tell you this
every time I've tried to use static
analysis in Python I found that it can
be incredibly hard even in fairly simple
situations there are some cases where
static analysis works pretty well so one
case is somebody asked me we have this
problem with imports in this very big
system we don't know what imports what
and we don't know the chain of
dependencies for imports it wasn't a
problem with circular imports because I
don't think anyone in this room has
probably run into a circular import
problem in a while but it was just an
issue with they didn't know where the
coupling in the code base was and
there's a static approach to solve this
and a dynamic approach to solve this the
dynamic approach would be to write an
import hook that logs every import and
so you could just run the system and see
how the imports perform the static
approach would be to write a node
visitor and just to find all the import
statements
for the most part in the majority of
code there's no use of path hooks
there's no use of import hooks there's
no use of the underscore underscore
import function there's no use of the
import library for the most part if you
see an import it's either from blah
import something import something and
that's the form and you can do that
static analysis even without
sophisticated tools like the ast library
you could do just with grepping which is
with regular expressions so there are
some cases where it works in a case like
this in a code analysis case like this
it ends up being very difficult and I
want to show you why now note I'm not
going to tell you why it's impossible
eval and Python makes it strictly
impossible to do this kind of static
analysis but that's a very trivial thing
to say because honestly the majority of
code that we look at is not going to be
some really weird eval code there are
some corner cases there are some places
in the standard library such as the
collections module where eval or exec
are used named tuple which we're all
familiar with is one very common case
where you see the use of dynamic code
generation and dynamic code execution
but for the most part it's still a
fairly obscure technique in libraries
one thing that we might assume is that
probably 99% of greater than 99% of the
common libraries who are looking at the
data science libraries like matplotlib
or Penn is that we're looking at are
encoded in what you might call a non
dynamic space of expressions what I mean
by that is actually have a rant for why
that's maybe a waste of Python but the
idea is that most of this code is
written not too different than a C or a
Java style it's written fairly
straightforward just classes and
functions and functions calling other
functions and the composition is at the
level of of breaking things into
functions and functions calling other
functions and many of the dynamic
features of Python monkey patching and
overloading are not really used now you
could say the code is written this way
because it's intelligible to just any
random contributor and I think that's a
really great reason to write code that
way you could say the code is written
this way because it's pretty
straightforward and we don't want to get
too complicated we don't want to
overload ourselves with too much
complexity for the sake of convexity if
it doesn't solve the problem and I think
that's a great reason as well
I will say that when I do see code bases
that are written in a very Java style I
think it is a waste of Python because it
turns out that these libraries
inevitably reinvent dynamic mechanisms
that are available in the language
themselves and very rarely do you see
those dynamic mechanisms invented in
order to get around limitations in the
mechanism in python so for example every
large system I've seen invents its own
configuration system except the import
mechanism and import hooks built into
the Python language itself give you
quite a bit of what you'd consider to
have to need in a simple configuration
system you have the ability to define
things in some format a Python file you
have you have the ability to pull them
into random parts of the program and
have some you know global state for the
configuration that's the import module
system is a global singleton right and
you have the ability to add some you
know code mechanisms and some overriding
mechanisms and you have all of that
available in pure Python with
supplemented by just a little bit of
mechanism around how imports work namely
import hogs but if we were to do the
stack analysis how do we do it
we probably do it using the ast module
using a node visitor so we'd identify
the calls within a call graph and we
build it and this turns out to be a
fairly undocumented thing but a pretty
simple thing to do so this is an example
of a node visitor this is a node visitor
that it gets an ast in abstract syntax
tree and every time it sees a call it
just prints out that it saw call and it
prints out what the function name was
and what arguments have solved and so
here's an example of a function and I'm
gonna run my ast node visitor on this
and you can see when I run it it sees
that there's a call to a function called
G here and a function called H there and
you might say well this is actually
pretty good because if I used an
approach like this on the panda's
codebase I could create a call graph I
could say this function calls this
function calls this function calls this
function and I could see what arguments
are passed and I could build a graph
that says this is the entry point and
all the arguments that are passed in and
here how they get passed down the line
to wherever they terminate wherever the
terminal function is that actually uses
those arguments and it turns out that
there are only a couple of ways that we
might consume these keyword arguments we
might
pop them we might subscript them so we
could figure out where a keyword
argument a star star star star argument
was actually used by just looking for
all the dot pops or all the subscripts
of that variable name one interesting
thing is we can always see when
something's passed on by keyword
unpacking because that itself will just
show up in the ast here I'm giving you
the names of the byte codes so if you do
a bytecode analysis rather than AST
analysis you'd see these byte codes and
you can also see where something
terminates you can easily see if a
function if the body of the function
never uses any of the arguments or where
it uses the arguments or where it
doesn't call anything else and you can
also kind of see where a function may
use unpacked arguments but the problem
is even in fairly simple code bases I
suspect it will quickly lose track of
bindings and I'll show you what that
means the easy binding that we'd expect
is we have some function f that calls
some other function G and it just passes
the keyword arguments down and here we
could see anything we pass into F gets
passed in the G G takes arguments a B
and C therefore F takes arguments a B
and C our analysis is done and that's a
fairly simple analysis and you might
expect that a lot of code looks like
this but I suspect that especially in a
library like matplotlib and especially
like the library like pandas you see
something slightly different that makes
this very difficult to statically
analyze instead you might see something
like this where you create some class
and then you pass those arguments to a
method and once you do this we
completely lose our ability to analyze
which of these two men which of these
two methods we went down into because we
have to know at runtime what this class
was and that could be determined by some
other state some other arguments and
suddenly the complexity of computation
that we have to track in order to figure
out which of these two paths down the
tree we went explodes I'd expect that
this is actually more the case than
you'd think and this shows up in some
very simple cases and so I would say
probably static analysis in this vein
won't lead you much of anywhere now of
course it's possible for us to have
unbounded complexity I don't have a lot
of time to go through all these examples
but I thought I'd come up with a couple
of aches
temples of just how complex an author
could just naively make it difficult for
you to statically track where an
argument went by doing copies of the
dictionary by updating the dictionary by
doing assignments in the dictionary and
then you have to track the state of the
dictionary by doing some really weird
things in the dictionary by using other
using the operator module to pull things
out of the dictionary but it is true
that we can always tell when you do a
star star keyword unpacking even if you
can't tell what God's key word unpacked
so it turns out that building this call
graph statically is very difficult one
of the main problems is the ast has no
knowledge of the symbol table so you
don't know the load context you don't
know if you see a name you know there's
a function by that name and you could
match it just nominally by seeing if
there are other functions in that module
with that name but you can't figure out
if it's being loaded globally if it was
locked into a closure you have no idea
and there's of course as you saw in the
last slide many many ways to obscure
this information so the other thought I
had was let's try doing this dynamically
if we were doing this dynamically we'd
have to have a test suite and the big
question that I'm not sure about is
whether we could use gallery code or
unit tests with sufficient coverage to
actually cover all the places where
arguments can be passed I think that the
matplotlib gallery is actually fairly
complete in terms of all the different
ways that you can pass arguments in and
I think that the coverage of the call
graph that it would generate would be
mostly complete but I'm actually not
sure in the case of pandas the unit
tests might be more or less complete now
there's a question whether or not this
could be included as a completeness
metric for the unit tests or for the
gallery so how do we do that well one
simple way we could do this is we could
just interrogate all the call functions
what I mean by this is do this if you
look at the C Python source code you can
see everywhere we're a byte code for a
call function every time you call a
function every time you have parenthesis
you call this byte code here and then it
ends up going into this function here
call function and this is a central
point for every time of functions called
so if you could interrogate this either
with something built into Python like
the line profiler or just by Spach
your Python source code you could see
every single function call and you could
build a call graph and if you had a
representative suite of code then
exercised all the code paths in your
library then you could actually get a
good call graph you can see that the
majority of this problem is actually in
building the call graph but there are a
couple questions about that I don't know
what the average depth of this would be
if there's average depth is fairly
shallow this might be too much of a
technique I don't know how much
branching there is I think these would
be very interesting metrics to track on
these libraries what's the average depth
of how many calls go down before you
actually hit the code that does the task
that you want is that the case that
pandas has many many many calls until it
actually calls the code that does the
work or is it actually fairly shallow
I'm not sure I don't have a gut feeling
for this how much branching is there how
much complexity is there in terms of one
convenience function of pandas and how
many possible things that could call
this could be a very meaningful metric
because this could tell you how testable
pandas is instead of being a test it
could give you a metric for this part of
pandas is very difficult to test because
it has so many modalities and I also
don't know how much noise there would be
in these measurements now I wanted to
show you one cute thing because you know
there's a surprise talk and I was put up
so I'll show you one module that I I i
presented a couple conferences ago and I
did a lightning talk at PI data London
about it's called our watch and it adds
read watches to Python so I'll show you
how you could do this kind of analysis I
will say before I show you the demo this
is a very weird patch it's a very
incomplete patch they can already get
some kind of interesting results from it
one interesting thing though about this
patch is even though it's extremely
obscure and extremely weird remember
this is an engineering problem where our
deliverable is better documentation so
it doesn't matter what technique we use
we can use some very obscure and very
absurd techniques as long as we generate
that documentation because our users
will never be exposed to those
techniques they'll only make use of
whatever results we get so hey how come
nobody thought of this all day long
oh that's what I get claps for okay so
here's my our watch module you you can
pimp install it you import our watch and
then in the sis module you have get our
watch and set our watch if you look at
the help text forget our watch it just
tells you that it gives you the read
watches the targets for the read watches
if you look at it for a set our watch it
just says it's a mapping of object IDs
to a function what this means is you can
create a callback
oops format object frame return object
how we can talk to that one more time
okay and then you can create an object
and then what you can do is you can say
every time somebody looks at that object
call my callback so I'll show you what
that means
every time somebody looks at the object
X it'll call the callback F so you can
see every time I trigger F X here I can
it's calling that callback so if I
create a function G that takes some
value Y and return twice Y times two if
I call G with X you can see it when I
pass it into the function
it triggers the callback inside the
function where it looks at it it took as
a callback think what we could do is we
could wrap at the entry point to our
gallery code we could wrap everything
with what these are watches then we can
immediately see where they're used how
they get piped we could build a data
flow graph for how the data moves
through all the functions in our library
so I'll show you a mocked up example of
that before I do that I want to show you
one really neat thing about this patch
notice how in the callback I returned
the object oh it's cut off a little bit
oh well let me there we go
notice how I return the object you can
return anything from this so look at
this I love this here's my callback if
the object is an integer return the
object x to otherwise return the object
oops from collections and then what you
do is you set an our watch not on a
specific object but on every object and
if that objects and energy return twice
so with this house but the consequence
of this is every number that you try and
put into your system gets doubled and it
really really confuses people when you
have x equals two and x times two what's
x times two if x equals two 32 how about
that I love that isn't that great okay
so I'll show you so one of the one of
the one of the purposes of this talk is
to show maybe a practical usage of
something like our watch because clearly
you'd never really want to do this
unless you really really really hated
your coworkers so let's say that you
have some code that looks like this this
is my simple module it has a function
called F it calls G and it calls H G
takes an argument a H takes an argument
B and I'd like to figure out that F
actually takes either a or b and I just
threw away the rest but you could think
that here I just want to figure out that
F takes F is actually takes a and B even
though I can't determine that from its
signature so I might have some test code
that looks like this here's my my
library code my my test code and it
creates three objects a b and c and it
just passes them to F and what I can do
is I can just annotate them like this
instead of passing those three objects I
just set an R watch on all three of the
objects so I set that hook on a B and C
and then when I run this whoops and then
when I run this you can actually see I
want to test annotated you can see that
the R watch was able to statically
determine what function and the line
number where each of those arguments
were looked at so what you could think
is when I call my matplotlib top I plot
a plot I could wrap all the things that
I put into it so I could go into the
gallery code from a clip at the entry
point where it calls these functions I
just wrap all the arguments of my or
watch or I just wrap everything with my
art watch and then I immediately know
the name of every variable and every
function works looked at and from
information I could build a call graph I
could build a data graph and I might be
able to build a supplement to the
documentation to say that plot function
actually takes these things and they're
used in this part of the code and I
could do that as an automatic generation
step which might be very useful so
that's the quark problem if you think
this is an interesting problem to solve
I'd love to talk to you you can tweet at
me at use this code thank you very much
thank you very much James I thought it
was a nice surprise
do we have any any questions thank you
for a call for a talk I think this is a
very annoying problem who has this
problem who's like quark everybody right
but I was thinking about why not try to
solve it from the documentation side
because normally when you look at the
documentation of for instance data frame
that plot you will see that the method
called in MATLAB is mentioned
specifically right so if there was some
convention to undertake that in the
documentation you could like recursively
build the commentation from right so if
you annotated what functions get called
I think the problem there is that that
could fall out of date and that's a lot
more burden I don't know that you'll be
able to convince the library authors to
do that also if you want a joke answer
that sounds like work and this is really
just fun well but you're and relying on
that the libraries will be tested right
so you're right it might be it might not
be an unreasonable part of the
documentation to say that this function
calls these other functions but the
problem is that even in very simple
cases
I suspect that you'd see that these
these convenience functions are creating
objects and calling methods on those
objects and they wouldn't be able to
even know there's there's too much
dynamism there there's there they're
using risk Afsar they're using
substitutability so that you know you
could pass anything and you could you
could inject any dependency so it may
not even be knowable do we have any
other questions
okay well please thank James Powell
again for a great talk